Puerto Rico the island of Ricky Martin
Bad Bunny Daddy Yankee and pina coladas
is also known for his unusual political
status because you see visualpolitik
viewers this island is not a state but
part an unincorporated territory of the
United States of America however this
could change very soon will Puerto Rico
become the 51st state of the United
States in this video we will tell you
all the details its status is as unusual
as it is controversial because Puerto
Rico despite being under U.S sovereignty
does not participate in the vote for
president nor does it vote for senators
or congressmen with voting rights
despite this Puerto Ricans have time and
again ratified their desire to remain
within this scheme however in recent
years something has been changing the
question arises are Puerto Ricans ready
to take the next step where is the
island of Enchantment headed well in
this video we're going to tell you all
the details let's get started
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
Puerto Rico has become the largest
economy in the Caribbean and the
standard of living on this island is
reasonably High obviously being closely
connected to the North American Giant
has certain benefits and perhaps that is
why both the government and the
Islanders themselves have practically
never embarked on any Independence
Venture they have always been very
attached to their Commonwealth regime
however the last few years have not been
easy and the model seems increasingly
out of date and is losing support in the
end Puerto Ricans are U.S citizens yes
but they have no real representation in
Congress they do not vote for federal
authorities and their justice system is
not entirely autonomous so in a way
Puerto Rico is still a colony perhaps
that is why Puerto Ricans themselves
have said enough is enough it is time to
move forward not to move away from the
United States but rather to fully
integrate with the North American Giant
and the question is is this really
possible and will we soon see Puerto
Rico become the 51st state of the union
what could such a change mean for the
island today in this video we're going
to answer these questions but before we
do that let's take a look at a little
history to understand and where it all
began let's get into it
[Music]
from Madrid to farakkar and Jones
during his second voyage to the American
continent Christopher Columbus came
across the island we all know today as
Puerto Rico its capital San Juan was so
named precisely in honor of Prince John
then Prince of Asturias and heir to the
throne of Castile and Aragon in what is
now Spain from that moment on and for
more than 400 years the Spanish Crown
maintained control of the island until
eventually a confrontation between Spain
and the United States changed this
relationship forever in the 19th century
in 1895 the Cuban War broke out in this
conflict pro-independence revolutionary
Rebels confronted the Spanish royalists
the pressure for the crown was
increasing and its position was more and
more compromised to try to alleviate the
situation and the increasingly strong
pro-independent sentiment Madrid
recognized both Cuba and Puerto Rico as
autonomous regions in 1897. however it
was not enough and what's more Uncle
Sam's help ended up backing the rebels
finally in 1898 a political military
clash between Spain and the United
States ended with a resounding defeat of
the old Empire the peace agreement that
was reached established that Cuba would
remain under American guardianship while
Puerto Rico Guam and the Philippines
became direct Colonial dependencies of
the United States
for the first time the United States
demonstrated not only its strength but
above all its status as a power and its
ability to intervene abroad to limit the
influence of other foreign powers
[Music]
however however despite this it was not
entirely clear what its relationship
would be with these new territories that
it now had under his control let's just
say that in Washington they didn't want
to emulate the Old Colonial scheme of
the Spanish or the British Empires which
makes sense after all this country
emerged as a reaction against the very
concept of colony well it was in 1900
when the then senator from Ohio Joseph B
farica led the Drafting and approval of
a law that bore his own surname the
forika ACT a law that established the
new political scheme that would be
applied from that moment on in Puerto
Rico for instance this law determined
that the president of the United States
himself would appoint a governor for
four years who would govern alongside an
executive Council in which at least five
of its 11 members would have to be
Puerto Ricans
[Music]
simultaneously a small local House of
delegates consisting of 35 members
chosen by the local population began to
function on the island for its part the
United States district court for Puerto
Rico was created to manage the Island's
judicial system and an appeals process
to the U.S Supreme Court was established
also despite not being a state Puerto
Ricans would be able to elect a resident
commissioner who would have a voice but
no vote in the U.S House of
Representatives
the states would be raised just 17 years
later
[Music]
in 1917 the Jones shafroth act signed by
then President Woodrow Wilson struck a
blow with its article 5. just take a
look at it all citizens of Puerto Rico
and all natives of Puerto Rico who were
temporarily absent from the island on
the 11th of April 1899 and have
thereafter returned to and are
permanently residing in said Island and
are not citizens of any foreign country
are hereby declared to be citizens of
the United States and shall be
considered and held as such the Jones
sharp Earth act 1917. suddenly something
very unusual for the time was done
Puerto Ricans were recognized as
citizens of the United States an
unprecedented privilege Puerto Ricans
were not born in a formal U.S state but
nevertheless enjoyed the same rights by
the way have you noticed what year this
law was passed well I say this because
it is said that this initiative has a
lot to do with increasing the recruiting
base in the midst of World War One of
course we can't know for sure if that
was the deciding factor
[Applause]
however the Jones shafroth act also
created a locally elected and much more
representative bicameral legislature a
chamber that became competent to
legislate on island Affairs of course
both the governor of the island and even
if necessary the president of the United
States had the rights to veto the point
is that in only 17 years Puerto Ricans
became U.S citizens and set in motion
the Prototype of their civil government
but what exactly is this island The
Colony a territory subordinate to the
United States while it's true that
Puerto Ricans are U.S citizens the
relationship of their land to the rest
of the country is quite different listen
up
[Music]
by the way before we continue if you are
someone who likes the world of Economics
don't forget to look at our new sister
Channel visual economic we'll leave you
the link in the description and up here
Commonwealth oh no unincorporated
territory
the government of Puerto Rico continued
to be elected from the Oval Office until
1947 when act 447 of the U.S Congress
established the possibility that the
island Governor would finally be elected
by the people themselves thus Luis Munoz
Marin became the first governor elected
by Puerto Ricans his administration
lasted no less than 16 years and was
absolutely key to the Island's status
for example in 1950 Manuel's Marine
managed to reach an agreement with
Washington for the approval of act 600
which gave Puerto Rico the possibility
of having its own state constitution as
the rest of the states of the Union
already had it was a kind of fundamental
law that established the organization of
the territory well in this text which
finally came into force in 1952 it
establishes that Puerto Rico is itself a
commonwealth attached to the United
States but since the text is also
ridding in Spanish the translation
speaks of a freely Associated state
which is the status that the island
still holds officially today
[Music]
this marked a turning point from that
moment on Munoz Marine's own idea was
that Puerto Rico should have more and
more autonomy as you're about to see
this is essentially the idea that modern
Puerto Rico is founded on and it defines
its particular relationship with the
United States take a look
another adventure
is
foreign
[Music]
Uprising took place a Revolt led by
armed pro-independent sectors that was
quickly put down by the security forces
let's just say that the whole free
Associated State thing was not really
apparent be that as it may in 1952
president Dwight Eisenhower gave the
go-ahead but demanded that a referendum
be held to ascertain the true will of
Puerto Ricans the elections were held on
4th of November of that same year and do
you want to know the result well no less
than 87.8 percent of the Islanders voted
in favor of the new constitutional
framework establishing the Commonwealth
the support was as you can see
overwhelming an absolute majority this
would be one of the many referendums in
which Puerto Ricans have expressed their
support for maintaining ties with
Washington we could almost say that the
second half of the 20th century was a
kind of honeymoon period between the
continental United States and Puerto
Rico look at this
Sanchez Valley the Arms Dealer who
changed history
[Music]
the second half of the 20th century was
a bed of roses for the Puerto Rican
economy around 1950 the U.S federal
government introduced a package of tax
incentives for U.S companies to settle
on the island generating a huge economic
boom look at the difference with the
rest of Latin America construction
hotels businesses new highways Puerto
Rico's economy began to flourish and of
course this had significant social
implications poverty was reduced and
practically all parameters improved for
years Puerto Rico was considered a
success story and take note because
since the first referendum was held in
1952 Puerto Ricans have been called to
the polls six times to express their
opinion on the sovereignty status of the
island they did so in 1967 1993 1998
2012 2017 and 2020. well in all of these
public surveys the link with Washington
won but in different ways
while the Commonwealth concept won until
2012 as of that year the option in favor
of becoming another state a formal state
of the United States gained a a clear
majority and the question is what caused
such a leap why did Puerto Ricans cease
to be satisfied with their current
status well in order to answer that
question we have to go way back to
September 2008 when Louis Sanchez de Val
was captured on the island for illegal
arms trafficking he was simultaneously
indicted on that charge by both the U.S
and Puerto Rican courts the defendant
then sued the state of the island by
declaring that a person could not be
charged twice for the same crime in the
same jurisdiction thus framing the
renowned case Puerto Rico V Sanchez Val
which was resolved in 2015 with a
controversial ruling Puerto Rico's
authority to prosecute persons derives
from the delegation by the United States
Congress and not by virtue of any
sovereignty of its own the adoption of a
constitution by delegation of Congress
to organize local government in
substitution for much of the organic law
then enforce did not represent a
secession of sovereignty to Puerto Rico
to the country Puerto Rico did not cease
to be a territory of the United States
Puerto Rico Supreme Court Doctrine as
you may be wondering so what is so
controversial about this basically
courts made it clear that the
sovereignty of Puerto Rico does not rest
with Puerto Ricans but rather remains in
the hands of Washington over the years
this concept along with economic
problems that we have already told you
about in past videos suddenly triggered
the ambition to change Puerto Rico
status
foreign
for example the island was practically
bankrupt with an external debt in excess
of 70 billion in fact it was not until
January 2022 that a federally appointed
Financial oversight committee managed to
restructure the public debt with
creditors but of course there is still a
long way to go before the problem can be
considered solved but do you know what
is most curious of all the funny thing
is that many of Puerto Rico's economic
problems if not the vast majority have
nothing to do with being a commonwealth
or the 51st state we're talking about
things like the Jones Merchant Marine
Act passed in 1920 and still in effect
today this is a law that prohibits
foreign flagged ships from transporting
goods between two U.S ports this makes
moving things to and from Puerto Rico
very expensive which obviously erodes a
lot of the Island's competitiveness why
is that but because U.S flagged and
crude ships are much much more expensive
to operate as an example this law makes
it impossible for large International
Freighters to unload Goods destined for
Puerto Rico on their way to or from the
US instead those goods have to make a
much more convoluted journey to get to
the island imagine Shanghai to Texas
reload Goods onto a U.S flagged ship
Texas to Puerto Rico and then we also
need to talk about things like the
minimum wage and federal subsidy plans
but in order to understand this look at
this chart
as you can see Puerto Rico is much much
poorer than the rest of the United
States however since it has to apply the
same federal minimum wage or an
abnormally high level of social benefits
in relation to what the parameters of
the island actually are and here the
problem is evident what is acceptable
for Texas does not have to be the same
for Puerto Rico you could say that
Federal policies and regulations mean
that when it comes down to it very few
people work in Puerto Rico that is one
of the main problems although yes it's
true that things are improving thanks to
new tax incentives for companies setting
up on the island well when it comes down
to it the fact is that none of these
problems would change if Puerto Rico
ceases to be a commonwealth and becomes
just another U.S state in fact some of
its tax benefits for businesses and
investors could just disappear
altogether yes the island would gain
more integration influence and probably
government investment but it would leave
many other things by the wayside be that
as it may the option of becoming another
state is the number one favorite of
Puerto Ricans take a look
[Music]
the status that went out of fashion
in 2020 Puerto Rico held its latest
referendum but this time neither
Commonwealth nor Independence was an
option the question was much clearer
should Puerto Rico be admitted
immediately into the Union as a state
this is exactly the question that was
asked in that referendum well the yes
vote obtained more than 50 of the votes
which gave the Island's government the
strength to Lobby in Washington it was a
campaign in which the current governor
Pedro Pierre luisi is involved but which
requires overcoming a very complicated
legislative circuit for example the
House of Representatives must pass a law
that enables a binding referendum for
the federal government that is an
election that not only allows citizens
to express their opinion as has been the
case up until now but also has legal and
political consequences that allow the
president of the United States to sign
the incorporation of the new state well
in December 2022 with 233 votes in favor
and 191 against the lower house
surprisingly succeeded in passing House
Bill 8393 the first step was thus
completed but there is still the Senate
and that visualpolitik Community is not
exactly piece of cake why well basically
because Puerto Rico is a very Democratic
territory politically
[Music]
in other words many Republicans are
afraid that what already happened with
Hawaii will happen again that Puerto
Rico will be a democratic stronghold
that will swing the majority in the
chambers particularly in the
non-proportional Senate where all states
regardless of their size or population
have two Representatives we have to go
Senator by Senator explaining to them
why it is fair to give equal rates to
American citizens residing in Puerto
Rico we also have to explain to them
that Puerto Rico is diverse that neither
should Republican Senators think that if
Puerto Rico becomes a state
automatically that means there will be
two senators and four Democratic
congressmen Pedro Pierre luisi governor
of Puerto Rico so the whole thing seems
complicated but who knows in any case
the Puerto Rican government has already
set 5th of November 2023 as the date for
a new referendum hoping that by then the
Senate will have given the green light
and these elections can be the final
step to becoming the 51st star on the
American flag or at least the 51st stake
because it seems that the flag will not
be changed we will see what impacts
there will be among Puerto Ricans if the
legislator closes the door again but for
now it's your turn do you think Puerto
Rico should become a new state what
benefits would this option have what do
you think about the Commonwealth status
the official comments here and if you
found this video interesting don't
forget to like And subscribe to
visualpolitik thank you very much for
being there all the best see you next
time
[Music]